[Music]
this is gonna be a quickie mood swings
Wiggin acne headaches sleep interruption
do you fancy any of those no we need
that alas these are some of the side
effects women have often had to put up
with for years when taking the
contraceptive pill so is music to my
ears then when I heard that the male
contraceptive pill has just passed
initial testing stages finally but don't
get too excited the product is likely to
be at least a decade away yet and not so
oddly enough they doesn't seem to be a
massive rush of companies desperate to
bring Michelle vision alright so okay
right so imagine this okay so bloke goes
out on a Johnny right he gets drunk he's
out on a night out on town right yeah
and you know he's had too much to drink
he's had too much to eat yeah he can't
really remember what he drank what he
ate
alright I'm very sorry celebrating okay
majid enough already you know and you're
out a date with him and he says all
right yeah let's carry on the night and
he wants to have fun and you say darling
have you taken your pill darling we
don't know if he's a boyfriend or a
partner but he wants to be something and
and he says he reassures you I've taken
my pill and then you know would you
trust him in the news you know I
personally even if the roles were
reversed and I'd met a woman that night
and she says yeah I've taken that I'm
always suspicious call it ego or
something that somebody wants to
replicate my genes so you know this
handsome face I would be evil with a
woman I'd be like I just met you darling
I'm not so sure I believe you've taken
your pill you know
so let's perhaps use some of this there
is this thing
I still wouldn't trust the dude sorry I
mean you know apart from coming from
accountancy of growing up on accounts
let's say I'm also a proud feminist and
you know I'm all for equality between
the sexes but on this one unless we
figure out a way of making sure that men
can get pregnant - yeah we're doing a
guy and it's like you see your friends
oh I'm pregnant
I thought he was on the pill so did I
you know I see them again
oh you pregnant again I thought he was
on the pill so did I no I wouldn't take
the chance
I wouldn't take such a pill well I'm
still wondering about the need for it
cuz it you know my it's long time that
I've had to worry about this kind of
thing and I never will again but in my
day you used to have what this sort of
pill and it was called a six-pack and
that sorted out and host mostly I think
yeah
sir 6-pack of fosters the most guys
right so um sorry I know if you come to
come to me something different actually
that this is an idea that somehow
everything has to be equivalent between
men and women and the truth is in this
particular case it's not the man will
never be left holding the baby
we are not equivalent here and my advice
to you as an older gentleman is don't
even go this way never never trust them
on that yes we saw a Joon's reaction
with hell no I almost liked reaction to
remain sure what do you take sure
relationship but I'm so and I would take
it and by the way I think I'm a
conscientious nice bloke and think well
I don't only say that I want another
child and it wouldn't actually work in
our so that's a lights it's not an
obscure I'm old
would you have trusted yourself in your
20s to take it regularly probably but in
your twenties your mind is ruled by
other things
oh yes got my new car and now I'm
considerably older would you trust the
Pope I guess it depends on the boy
Friday when I knew I was doing this
debate I asked my boyfriend would you
take the male pill and he went well it
depends what the side effects are and I
was like we're good acne actually you
mentioned that we're not the same and
actually we can see that in the
contraceptive options that are available
that's all the availability for women in
terms of contraceptive choices you know
implants ejections patches systems
devices rings and female condoms and
diaphragms and oh and then the mountain
has now potentially the male pill and
then that word I cannot say without
shuddering you said it marriage word
let's call it the V word is irreversible
so once your if a man does choose to do
that I would advise risks the problem is
with the male contraceptive there's
still a risk in the same ways there is
for a female contractor but with the
additional problem that you know if the
risk goes wrong yeah but the cost woman
and it's not substantive to the man
that's that's Wyatt Ennis and that's
until we can make sure the men can get
pregnant - I wouldn't trust it you said
that you would take it by the way so if
I spoke to you about the side effects
would that put you what bloating yeah a
little bit and you'll decide like you
know if one if you've got children one
of you will go to work and one you've
you stay here yes and you'll you'll make
a judgement about that and it may be
very healthy in a relationship for the
girl to have a period sorry I have a
time off break but this is not what this
is really about this is about
trying to make sure that they equalize
the idea of contraception I as a woman
sex have to take all the responsibility
unfortunately it's a fact I might not be
in agreeable for under life yeah imagine
18 year old boy probably says I've taken
up just because he wants sex so many
mothers single mothers very naive in
doesn't understand we stick with the
pills that we've got but now as Aintree
revelers hang up their hats and put away
their fascinators you might be mistaken
in thinking that the biggest race in the
UK calendar is over for another year but
with Parliament at war and to resume
promising to step down the conservative
leadership contest will soon be well
away and it's probably only a matter of
time before labour follow suit but one
MP who's not willing to become politics
answer to tiger role is Trevor's secret
sister Labour's Jess Phillips this is
what the Birmingham Yardley MP had to
say Birmingham obviously which only
became famous at the moment I feel so
tired I can't think of a job at least
like to have than to be the leader of
the Labour Party doesn't look like much
fun at the moment and it's funny she
also went on to say how much Theresa May
and Jeremy Corbyn have aged recently so
Jess Phillips for saying what everyone
at home is thinking you are our straight
talker of the week that's all we've got
time for this week don't forget if you
want to join in the debate all you need
to do is just search for the pledge on
Facebook or Twitter thanks for watching
bye
[Music]